but this let's jump let's jump over to
the next story here the one that i think
is actually more uh more important cnn
faces calls to fire don lemon over jesse
smallett's court testimony now i'll say
this i lean towards they probably should
and folks that don't know the story don
lemon getting privy information because
of the resources at cnn messages jesse
smallett when this is going down telling
him you know the police don't trust you
and basically giving him uh aid and
advice now cuomo got fired for something
similar but i think what cuomo did was
substantially worse if jesse smilet and
don lemon were friends and they're in
communication i don't think it's the
worst thing in the world but
don lemon goes on tv only a few hours
after jesus millet implicates him saying
he was giving telling me what was going
on behind the scenes
don lemon reports on the issue as if
he's not connected at all no calling out
the conflict of interest they then have
the guests coming on saying oh the
testimony this the testimony that
cnn is corrupt now jeff zucker the
president said he would have fired chris
cuomo sooner he wanted to well here's
his opportunity he can fire don lemon
and say listen you want to interfere in
high-profile stories that you are
covering
termination
that's what it is there's not going to
be anybody left over there
and aren't they being acquired aren't
they being acquired by discovery is that
right discover
isn't cnn being acquired
isn't there isn't there an entire shift
in programming being planned for cnn
what you mean like it's going to turn
into the loop of a toilet flushing no
that that that they were trying to
return to quote more just straight news
did i miss i don't know i don't see that
anymore i don't i don't see that i mean
that's uh that's in the uh parallel
universe where everything is opposite
and uh and that's also where hell has
frozen over yeah
you know what you know the president of
cnn jeff zucker you notice uh what he
used to do
what's up he was uh
he worked with donald trump on the
apprentice he made reality tv yeah this
is from cnn business uh cnn's set to
change corporate hands for the second
time just a few years as a t spins off
all of warner media in a transaction
with zaz labs discovery inc that's from
cnn.com from
uh may of 2021 discovery and it's called
what the warner media and their and
their goal is to transition cnn away
from this character and columnist and
opinion driven stuff towards
this is what they're saying in the news
don't give me that i'm looking at you
because i'm saying i was just going to
say they have a very tough job ahead of
them
very difficult to do indeed but there's
going to be none of those guys left
maybe they're happy to see cuomo maybe
they're happy to see don is it lemon
lemon
so a t owns warner media that owns cnn
is this the way it works pretty sure
okay they sold the building their their
building a few years ago i think they've
just been crumbling
crazy no no cnn
yeah cnn's been crumbling well after
trump their ratings have gone down
dramatically and they have continued to
go down dramatically and the only way
that they were able to get ratings is to
fear monger about kovid they were
literally i think it was project veritas
that exposed them uh correct me if i'm
wrong i'm going to have to double check
them but had one of their producers
talking about how they loved having the
death count on the screen because they
they got more ratings and they got more
fear-mongering and they got more of an
emotional response that had more people
tune in into their propaganda when of
course they they they did that bull crap
they said the death numbers for kovad
were gang busters for ratings they used
that word gang busters and it's that's
can we add a counter to our show that
we're like you know
live saved by joe rogan yes
publicly announced but there's probably
more aaron rodgers uh dana white um
all the brilliant doctors rogan's had on
his show because he has like health
nutritionists and doctors and like
educators and he takes all this
information and kind of packages it for
people and all of them get healthy the
next day and the corporate media freaks
out and tries to destroy and obliterate
and and slander him for for helping you
see sarah silverman no she on her
podcast she came out and she was like i
see the lies i see it on the left and
the right like the horse dewormer stuff
this is sarah silverman sannis she's
like
ivermectin is prescribed by doctors for
all sorts of things but the left just
keeps saying a horse dewormer because
they're trying to make the other people
look stupid and then she puts it on
twitter and i was like wow i mean yes
you are correct thank you sarah
silverman uh talk to your doctor of
course and then everyone's responding to
it saying
sarah you're wrong it is horse dewormer
so cnn's telling the truth yeah
dana white had a very interesting
comment today because he was asked about
the joe rogan therapy that he went under
and he said he even had a family member
that was obese that was a smoker that
had diabetes that was in one of the
worst shapes that you could possibly
imagine and they got better within 24
hours and he said all the people
criticizing them all the people
attacking him you know what just don't
take it go lay in a hospital room or go
into isolation for 10 days and deal with
this on your own if you don't like it
you don't have to take it don't here's
more on that story the the mourner media
apparent company of cnn discovery is set
to merge jeff zucker's future is in
jeopardy he's not quote this according
to fox not the supreme ruler he was
anymore when they quote made him fire
cuomo that's in fox news.com today
this is an interesting story that could
actually have some implication on the
rest of culture and politics and such if
cnn takes a major shift in tone they're
they're losing all their content
creators yeah yeah well i mean they're
pushing them out
right what do they got they're banned
you know they got the brian
yeah it's amazing i can't when i heard
uh oliver darcy's gonna be on the main
desk pretty soon wow
i mean at least they reported about how
biden secretly the binding admins have
uh secretly been meeting with the press
to garner favorable coverage and that
it's been working right that was because
they don't they don't understand that
they are crooked like they genuinely
think this is the scariest thing they
think they're like nobles they're so
wise and smart
and that's that's the thing you know
it's the in the banality of evil these
people don't think they're doing
anything wrong so oliver darcy is like
media organizations have been secretly
meeting with the administration so that
they can help swing coverage more
positively to reflect on biden and it's
like you realize that's like seriously
implicating for the press and they're
like they just don't they report it like
it's normal yeah that's called state
propaganda that they willingly admit and
brag that they collude in secret meeting
with white house officials trying to
paint the economic uh picture better
than it is right now and and the
economic picture is pretty bad so uh
objectively that yeah it's hard
it is common for uh
the government to give reporters
background information to help explain
to them all the issues and whatever but
at the same time this is really about
driving like the information stories and
the account right secret meetings
because biden's approvals in the gutter
yeah with these news organizations to
lobby them to give biden better coverage
is beyond reproach
and laughing at oliver darcy being
sucked up the hierarchy like coming
coming from business insider making into
cnn having having the whole the whole
upper echelon just like cleared out and
then be like oh you're a news guy from
business hey let's move you right on up
the chain who's replaced cuomo
i don't watch cnn i i guess it was a
more moderate gentleman which i'm
relatively optimistic but it does look
like they're firing people to make room
for this new buy out that they're doing
i was going to say to your point you
were talking about how they think that
they're in the right so c.s lewis talks
about how the thing that you should
really care about the thing that you
should really worry about is not the
people who are malicious for malice's
sake but people who genuinely believe
that they are doing the right thing and
i'm starting to think that's what cnn
thinks they're doing because they seem
to be completely oblivious to the fact
that maybe they shouldn't be having
secret meetings i disagree i don't think
so you think they know that they're
doing what they're doing is wrong at the
high at the higher level i think maybe
it's like smeagol you know from lord of
the rings to use that reference once
again i i think they know they're
polishing a turd
i think i don't know they have a whole
bunch of
family-friendly show but they have a
whole bunch of that on them on
themselves and they're trying to polish
up and they know what they're doing you
can't get away from the smell you can't
get away from reality mythbusters has
proven you can polish a turtle oh oh
really yeah yeah they did it it was
shiny that's crazy oh yeah so that's
what cnn's doing but let's be real let's
be real i have nothing to say to that no
no hold on add anything you can
you can in fact polish a turd but guess
what it's still a turd of course so cnn
can do whatever they want to try and get
it get away but like you were saying you
know just now the stink remains
so if
you know you're they're going to have
some guy walk up and be like oh that's a
shiny brown
what is that
did you polish feces and cnn's going to
be like
yes
there's other references i want to make
here but it's a family-friendly show but
but one theory that i have is that
there's a lot of people that are being
absolutely overpaid at cnn their ratings
are growing down their revenue is going
down their advertisements going down
they're they're interested in the
buy-off as we're hearing about so this
could be also an attempt of them
offloading a lot of their big contracts
we saw uh chris cuomo argue with jeff
zucker and publicly even release a
statement saying jeff sucker knew
everything that i was doing and now he
decides to fire me so and he had he had
a fat contract don lemon fat contract
they don't deserve
that ridiculous limousine liberal money
but they get it and i think now they're
facing the the ramifications of them
going too crazy
and and imagine they're trying to make
their own way in the independent
immediate space
do you guys remember when don lemon
pretended like he was quitting
yeah he was like this is the last the
last show just for ratings yup i
remember that and then everyone was like
oh don lemon hints that he's quitting
and then the next day he's like we were
just changing the name of the show oh my
god
it was like it was like cnn tonight with
don lemon and now it's like don lemon
tonight or something
and so he made it seem like he was
quitting these people are pathetic
in the same vein as jesse whatever his
smolet kamala that's why the friends
lemon but but you know the other thing
too is about about don lemon he's also
been accused of assaulting that guy yeah
he's being sued over it right so it's
like bro you got cuomo with his
harassment thing and you got him with
his collusion thing and he you got
something similar with don lemon
could you imagine
let me tell you so you know you know
we're we're we're making new shows here
at tim castle i heard we got pop culture
crisis and we're looking for talents
i couldn't imagine like look like
walking into like a conference room
where it's like um mr pool your your
on-air talent applicants are available
and i was like oh can i walk in it's
just don lemon sitting there that's like
that's cnn like jeff sucker walks in and
he goes
oh jeez
all right don you're all we got oh gosh
make it work right but they're paying
them a lot of money they're paying for
six million yeah i think they're paying
them four million
four
million dollars a lot of money
and on tv to pay paid for by a million
dollars on this contract was it
seventeen i don't know google
pharmaceutical advertising biggest
revenue source for for cable news i
believe and then also straight into
their pockets so
they're basically just paid stills for
pharmaceuticals for the people taking
giving you the vaccine there you go i
wish you i wish it was more like you
know they used to do tv shows in the 50s
where
the commercial was actually like the
opening part of the show and it's like
you get that wholesome show where the
dad walks in you know for like he wakes
up and he comes downstairs what's for
breakfast honey she's like today we're
having mapleson's pancakes and she holds
it up like they're the best pancakes for
your family and the kid runs and he's
all excited i would love that if that's
what cnn was doing like don lemon sits
down he cracks open a pharmaceutical
like a pill bottle and he's like i
better take my meds otherwise i might go
crazy and
eat his pills allegedly to the uh
according to the new york post chris
cuomo is prepping a lawsuit against cnn
for the remaining 18 million dollars on
his contract
that's a lot of money
you got to sell a lot of big pharma ads
to get that kind of money and if you if
you ever
have the misfortune of of turning the
channel on the boob tube and going on
cnn you're more likely to see a whole
bunch of side effects mentioned uh from
all the big pharma advertisements that
they run on there if they're not running
segments paid for by pfizer check this
one out i missed this one this from a
couple days ago this is new york post
chris cuomo prepping to sue cnn for more
than 18 million dollars over contract
they say fired cnn host chris cuomo said
to sue for 18 million dollars his hired
lawyers is preparing to file a lawsuit
over the remainder of the four-year
contract he signed last year after a
bitter back and forth about what the
network knew of his secret efforts to
aid his brother
his contract was reportedly worth 6
million annually leaving between 18
million and 20 million dollars that he
would be owed sources said adding that
chris cuomo would also likely seek
damages
this dude's getting paid that much money
well i don't understand it i really
committed a crime and got fired for that
he's not going to get anything when you
integrate when you do the bidding of the
special interests and the multinational
corporations they have a way of
rewarding you and that's one of the way
they reward you is it not only just a
way to reward you but is it not almost
required
for these evil doers to pay people that
much money to be evil like that
yeah that's what the price of his soul
is is is he evil or is he just stupid i
mean
i think i think honestly i think he's i
think they're evil and you know for a
while i've been like well you know never
attribute to malice blah blah blah but
when chris cuomo pretended to be in look
in quarantine like okay that's evil yeah
and
but i gotta say
i don't know if you got i don't know if
it's that you have to pay people to
overcome their scruples or that people
who are evil know that their vet their
evil is valuable you know what i mean so
like basically you get a bunch of evil
people being like look cnn we know that
you know you want to hire a bunch of
evil people and we know you got to pay
top penny for the good evil people so
chris cuomo was like i'm evil you know
and you got to pay
so cnn's like i guess we have to because
you get a regular person they're going
to be like i'm not going to lie on tv
diabolical the dumber diabolical
questions been answered diabolical well
when i was doing a lot of press coverage
on the ground whether it was covering
the g8 or the nato meetings a lot of
times when i walked in there they had
parties and then after parties and then
they had champagne everywhere a lot of
these top media figures have huge
substance abuse problems they pop pills
they drink a crap ton of alcohol i had
the
fortune of actually getting hammered
with the white house press corps at
bilderberg uh one year and they are
absolute substance abuse
uh
people who have tortured souls some of
them some of them i would say are evil i
i think we shouldn't generalize because
there are some people that are trying to
do a good job but by and large a lot of
them are either just drug abused
alcoholics or just evil people associate
pets where does that money come from
the government fighters send me your
text message listen listen listen we
were talking with man the other day
about co-opting and you know he's saying
you know someone's going to come along
and offer you 200 million dollars and
they're going to be like but maybe you
know you shouldn't have luke on the show
he's a little too edgier and that's what
they try to do right this is what cnn is
how do they get the money to pay chris
cuomo six million dollars a year when he
gets lower ratings than we do in the key
demo and i think he barely gets more
than us with all viewers with all due
respect perhaps the question we should
be asking is why don't we have pfizer as
a sponsor that's a great question
that's great you know um i you know you
know i'm thinking about it right now and
i think five boosters uh
hit me up yeah yeah wink wink but but
this this would be obvious to everybody
because i'll tell you this running a
company looking at ad rates looking at
cpms here's what's fascinating to me and
something that kind of you know was a
surprise when i started you know when
i'm getting into this business and the
company's growing i get these
advertisers hitting me up and they're
like hey we want to advertise on your
show here's our offer and i'm like
that's a ridiculously low sum of money
i'm not interested
and then it turns out i'm like talking
to these reps and they're like that's a
normal amount of money for the
viewership that you have and then i was
like no that can't make sense i mean i
know how much these other networks
charge and i know their ratings and i
know we have higher ratings than them
and they're like uh-huh
some something's rigged right it's plain
and simple so if cnn
is is what is what is cuomo's writing
let's pull up cuomo's ratings let's pull
up cnn ad what is it add week ratings
and uh let's let's see what they got
december 5th what day should we go with
we got monday december 6th scoreboard
cnn what what what what time period was
cuomo on was he on at nine anderson
cooper got a hundred and fifteen
thousand people in the key demo what
that's it it
that's insane one hundred and fifteen
thousand people in the key demo
from uh eight pm to nine pm and then uh
tonight whatever is 123 000. don lemon
108 000 and then 110 000. carlson gets
half a million in the key demo
in one hour so we don't we you know he's
he's a little bit more than double what
we end up getting for the most part but
live then when you look at cnn's total
viewership this is people who are older
anderson cooper is only getting seven
hundred and eight thousand carlson's
getting three million wow massive but
anderson cooper 708 000
that i i would say
the way we structure our show because
it's the the show and the clips we
absolutely get more than that across the
board in the key demo definitely the key
demo being what 35 to four twenty twenty
five to fifty four yeah is the is the
you know the whatever that says twenty
five fifty four demographic we actually
get eighteen year olds in there as well
he didn't 24. like the entirety of my
demo was like 25 to 55 men basically
yeah i think the average age for us is
like 29 or something 29 year old dudes
and so when i start looking at how these
ad rates work and what's going on you
start to realize
it's all fake
cnn isn't making the money for this
maybe they are maybe there my opinion
based on what i know they're probably
not they're probably not it's like
google's not making the money for their
ads it's alphabet subsidizing it att
subsidizing cnn i just looked up at t
government contracts and i mean 3.3
billion from the nsa this is three years
ago we live in a communist country
mm-hmm sort of
the government determines
he gives money out weird investments
federal reserve the whole system
obfuscates where how money is printed
and where it goes and then somehow you
end up with chris cuomo getting getting
what like a 24 million dollar contract
24 million bucks it says here uh total
google first result total cnn revenue
1.7 billion
how how is that possible
that's because that must be because the
ad buyers from northrop grumman and
pfizer and the rest of them are bad at
making choices or
they know that there's a certain segment
of people that make influence on
contracts and propaganda and that it
makes sense for them like have you ever
wondered why you're watching tv show and
there's an ad for like a fighter jet
yeah right it's not because you're going
to buy a fighter jet it's to like prime
you to make it okay that they're buying
fighter jets from northrop grumman or
whoever whoever makes something i
remember when i was like a kid and first
i started to understand how
advertisements worked and i never really
thought about it until i was watching
daytime tv and they kept advertising
diapers and stuff exactly like why are
they advertising tampons to me and then
i was like you're watching the wrong
show bro
i get it now
they're looking for you know so the
internet really changed things because
ads can be served by the individual yeah
and now now it's just now it's just
creepy it's really funny when you'll see
people they'll be like why is facebook
advertising this to me and then
everyone's like uh bro like that's
that's what you're wearing
yeah i just got an advertisement for
some gauntlets i almost bought them
medieval gauntlets yeah i had to stop
myself tomorrow you're gonna get
advertisement for a polished herd
and this is actually weird to me because
i'm like why are they all of a sudden
advertising this
i haven't because i've been doing keto
for a while and i haven't been well i
should say i call it colloquial keto
like i haven't been hardcore testing
strips and like measuring you know fat
content stuff but i've been doing heavy
fat low sugar high protein and so it's
like it's you know it's pretty good
but i don't google search any of this
stuff yeah i it's not part of my
lifestyle i literally just like i don't
want to eat the donut just give me the
jerky and then all of a sudden on
instagram it's just advertising this
stuff to me it's probably hearing your
voice say keto keto keto and your google
watch i wonder if it's sending your
biometrics to the lab and they're like
he will his he will like keto bars he
needs protein he likes protein
they can tell if you have a heart rate
spike as you observe an advertisement
yeah to know that if you get more of
them well also a lot of theoretically a
lot of the tvs that people are buying
are very affordable and very cheap
compared to what they were a few years
ago because now they data harvest what
you watch how far you're paying
attention to something some tvs are even
equipped with cameras with microphones
so the level of spying that has been
happening here by the major corporations
is absolutely intense and there was even
a couple moment moments between me and
you tim we were talking about something
privately and then a couple moments i
walk away i'm on i'm on my newsfeed and
i see an advertisement for twice i i
can't remember right now right now what
it was uh but twice i remember we were
talking privately walk it away go on
social media and it's right singularity
there's two there's a couple issues here
one is surveillance bad obviously put
that aside for now but in terms of like
receiving targeted advertisement which
is better to just be sitting there like
seeing a torrent of like tied tampon and
midall commercials or to actually get
commercials for something that you find
interesting that you may actually want
to buy no no no no i disagree with you i
just asked a question i didn't even make
a [ __ ] how dare you
would be better it would be better to
get random ads you know why the most
annoying thing to me is i'm like oh man
we need we need a hammer i'll just order
one and i'll go online i'll type in like
order hammer online and then i click buy
and i overnight shipping and then for
the next week
every ad is like every different kind of
hammer and i'm like yo i bought it
already like i don't need another one so
the target so the targeted advertising
is just not as good as it needs to be to
make you happy they need to also know
when the loop is closed so i i swear to
god this happened one time i bought a
pair of shoes a year later i got an
advertisement for the exact same pair of
shoes a year later and i had just been
thinking to myself i want to replace
these shoes so to me that was like
actually helpful because oh yeah i was
just thinking about that click boom
bottom in austin we were talking about
doing cryotherapy just a conversation
between me and you literally got an
ad for cryotherapy as we're down there
bro facebook knows
yeah okay so uh how how principled are
we then if we walk around with these
devices in our product in our pockets
all the time obviously not very yeah
jack if you if you if a genie
magic genie just appeared before you and
was like i'm going to give you the
ability to fly yeah you could fly yeah
but you're going to be half as strong as
you are now
would you take it well i'm pretty strong
so yes you cut your overall strength in
half which you can fly
yeah i could i could do that i have room
for that so with these devices this is
the this is the the the the faucet what
bannon called the faustian house yeah
the faustian deal or whatever bargain
that we get this device that seriously
empowers us hooks us up to the network
we can tweet we can share our ideas we
can produce content we can find things
but in exchange a part of our soul is
captured by the device that's indeed
that's that absolutely true now there
are alternative models for this right
john rob is somebody who went but who
not only wrote a book called brave new
war who not only advised people not only
created rss right but now he's like
actually he went to congress and advised
congress on this how there are ways that
we can own our own data so that we can
actually enjoy the benefits of this and
not sell our souls and get the benefit
of our you personal data which i think
would be an a welcome advance in this
environment but i don't see that
happening with like smart tvs and smart
refrigerators how do we kind of get
around
that us becoming the product at that
stage
i remember i mean tim spent like an
entire day going to a special store just
so i could buy a tv that didn't have a
microphone and a camera and an internet
connection to it so you know it's
becoming harder and harder but that's
the things that you have to do what was
this special store called flea market uh
no it was actually a best buy and it was
one of the best buys that had one of the
few televisions that didn't have an
internet connection that didn't have a
microphone and camera but what was what
was the why that when you've got this
thing listening to you constantly
because i could put this away whenever i
want i see like a tv's in my room you
can't really move it around you can't
you can't put this in a box you can't
put that on your wrist there uh it's a
it's a whoop it's a health tracker is it
listening i just signed up to get the
four when it's released
it's going to take forever
yeah thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at
8pm now don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you